كيف يمكنك الاستمرار في محاكمة
هذه الحرب إذا نفدت
ذخيرتك ولم يتم تعزيز الإنتاج بعد
أولاً، لقد ناقشت كثيرًا مع جنسن
أيضًا مع بوريس وزير الدفاع في
ألمانيا ووزيرة خارجيتي أنالينا
أنه يتعين علينا تغيير  طريقة
التعامل مع الصناعة،
لذلك في السنوات الأخيرة
اعتقدنا أكثر فأكثر أن
العلاقة بين
إدارة الدفاع العام والصناعة
تشبه إلى حد كبير
الشركة التي تشتري سيارة،
لذلك يوجد دائمًا مخزون من السيارات
هناك  الإنتاج الدائم يوجد
دائمًا ما تحتاجه للصيانة
بالطريقة التي قمنا بها في الماضي خلال العشرين
عامًا الماضية أو نحو ذلك، حيث طلبنا ذات مرة
واتفقنا على
توقف الإنتاج لأننا اشترينا بالفعل
ما نحتاج إليه لذا يتعين علينا ذلك  نفهم
أنه من أجل أمننا علينا أن نغير
طريقة التعامل، هذه الحقيقة نحتاج إلى
إنتاج دائم
لأهم الأسلحة التي نستخدمها وهذا
أيضًا بسبب مسائل الصيانة
وهذا أيضًا بسبب مسألة
الذخائر
وبالتالي هذا  ما نتعلمه ولكن
تعلمه يعني أننا
نتخذ الآن إجراءات في حالة قدراتنا الدفاعية القديمة
ولكننا نفعل ذلك أيضًا
لدعم أوكرانيا